that i think having somebody like boris
johnson as the prime minister of this
country is a tragedy for all of us mps
yes but also for everybody in this
country because if you look at the scale
sorry problems that we have
sorry jonathan we're just going to cut
across you victoria atkins home office
minister has resigned um that is another
big name isn't it um it's a resignation
it's not just uh somebody uh putting in
a a letter saying that they have
withdrawn their lack of confidence that
victorians can figure that we've
interviewed lots lots of times on sky
somebody that that may well be known to
the viewers i'll just pause our people's
panel up pmc's panel to bring in uh ali
fortescue he's here with me that is a
big name isn't it again for the prime
minister to lose yes another big name
every time we look down we are seeing
more people on those sort of middle
ranking ministerial roles going victoria
atkins she was a home office minister
someone who has been out on the media
around defending the prime minister at
the height of the various scandals that
we've been through
she has resigned she has tweeted out a
letter and of course she joins likes of
john glenn treasury minister
will quince children's minister robert
walker schools minister felicity buckin
pps laura trott pps we are seeing
the drip drip i mean it's more of a sway
now of junior middle ranking roles in
government people who no longer have
confidence in the prime minister
and i think what is striking i think is
the wording on some of these
these resignation letters and also from
mp's back bench mps i mean we had lee
anderson back bench np you said
integrity should come first and here we
go we've got this letter now and in it
she says that the values such as
integrity decency respect and
professionalism should matter to us all
i have watched with growing concern as
those values have been fractured under
your leadership through paterson
partygate and pinscher i have given you
the benefit of the doubt at each turn
out of loyalty to you as prime minister
and to our great party the events of
this week however made those contortions
impossible the casual mistreatment of
minister will quince and the revelations
concerned in northern mcdonald's let her
highlight just how far your government
has fallen
from those ideals i can no longer
pirouette around our fractured values we
can and must be better than this that
that line better than this is a line
that's been echoed in a couple of the
letters that the country deserves better
than this the voters deserve better than
this she's saying that we as a party
must be better than this
this is at a time when our constituents
face grave costs of living pressures
the challenges demand resolute focus we
cannot provide that focus at present and
then she goes on to say how proud she is
of
various elements of her role and people
that she would like to thank and thanks
for the opportunity to serve and deliver
and it says she says it is with sadness
that i step away but but again ali
really really strong words the
government has fallen from ideals we can
and must be better than this these are
real value judgments on him
as a person
and and the party now as it stands yeah
pirouette around our fractured values
that was a line that struck me i mean
nicola richards yesterday another
junior member of government said the
party is currently unrecognizable um so
i think
this is about integrity and we we saw
that i think in the letters too from
sajid javid and rishi sunak last night
british sunak saying government needs to
be conducted with a degree of
sensibleness um so it is
now i think very hard to see what the
prime minister is going to say at prime
minister's questions what the mood will
be i mean will
the benches be empty behind him
what will the state of his own party be
when he goes in that chamber and
addresses parliament and the nation what
is he possibly going to say that is
going to get people back on side and
he's leaving it quite late isn't he it's
22
he doesn't normally cut it quite this
fine although he has left at this time
but before it has to be said let's just
quickly return to our our parliamentary
panel um before prime minister's
questions christine jardine from the
liberal democrats i mean obviously
opposition parties you must be rubbing
your hands at all of this but
in terms of of what it tells the party
about politicians uh
it's fair to say that this certainly not
only damages the conservative party but
it damages the whole institution doesn't
it of politics and parliamentarians
there is no glee for any of us to take
in this
shambles and
unprecedented
debacle from this government um and can
i just say i am so you know
victoria atkins um resigning she is
someone i worked with in the domestic
abuse bill i have huge respect for her
and the fact that she finds this prime
minister and this government impossible
to work with anymore speaks volumes i
think but there's no glee for anyone in
our country being put through
this and the people in this country
deserve so much better and
i before i was a politician i was a
journalist and i studied
politics university british political
history i can remember nothing
on the magnitude of the scale of this
complete and utter debacle and
mismanagement a prime minister who will
go to pmq's today if indeed he goes
because i'm beginning to wonder
um
with very little of his front bench left
very few of his ministers left
this is a scandalous way for the country
to be governed
um christian jordan thank you very much
uh john stevenson back to a conservative
mp for carlisle
do you think he'll resign today
well we'll have to wait and see i mean i
actually thought he would probably
resign last night but i think what
you're now seeing is
the seeping away of any support from the
for the prime minister you've seen
junior ministers you're seeing pps is
all starting to resign and i just think
there's no going back now i just cannot
see how the prime minister can survive
this uh and it wouldn't surprise me if
we see his resignation later today and i
think it's the right decision i look
back to the 1719 parliament when you
know there was it was a big issue there
was a lot of turbulence at that time but
it was about a policy this is not about
a policy this is about culture this is
about values this is about a personality
and i think that's not healthy for
british politics i think we've got to
get away from this and get back to the
discussions about policy issues that
actually matter to the people of this
country instead of having this
this
circumstance i just think is just very
unhealthy and has been brought about by
one personality
and if he does indeed resign if he does
go
how quickly do you feel i mean we've got
recess coming up in a couple of weeks
this is when parliament breaks for the
summer um how quickly do you think
potentially things could change oh we
think the prime minister might be coming
out is it all over prime minister are
you going to resign boris johnson
well no words from boris johnson uh
sky news team along with pretty much
every other broadcaster shouting out
will will he resign um and is it all
over for him now
um
a smile for the media but it wasn't
certainly quite spoiled soon as he has
in the past um and is that
card now heads down to uh the palace of
westminster for prime minister's
questions very much leaving a little bit
late uh quarter to uh 12. we're
expecting prime minister's questions to
start on the dot you can see there from
our helicopter shots
the prime minister leaving there are
protesters outside the gate of downing
street as there have been
repeatedly throughout brexit and
throughout the last few months so he
will be having to drive past those and
then on to the houses of parliament
where it will be really fascinating to
see what he will face
uh ali foster your political
correspondent saying you know will you
face empty benches behind him we've had
so many uh conservative mps over this
morning and over the last 24 hours
either resigning or saying they don't
have confidence in the prime minister
any longer
what will he be facing from his own side
when he gets into prime minister's
questions let alone what he will face
from the opposition
let's briefly return to our our
politicians panel jonathan reynolds
labour mp joining us and jonathan over
the last few weeks kierstarma um hasn't
really attacked the prime minister
personally he has very much focused on
cost of living some people have
criticized that some people have said
you know he's not really going in for
the for the sucker punch when he could
do this is the prime minister who's
fighting for his political life
and kirsten
instead takes the moral high ground and
talks about the politics rather than
what is swirling around government and
what's swirling around the media do you
think he will take the same view today
do you think that he kierstama will
continue to go on on cost of living
don't think the two issues are as
distinct as as you might suggest i mean
the tragedy of this this is
unprecedented i don't think anyone has
ever been on a panel like this where the
government is literally falling apart uh
in real time but the real tragedy of
this is we're losing a competent
administration no matter which political
party you support we're losing competent
government people literally being in
charge of government departments at a
time when the pressures on people are
extreme and it's you know this shouldn't
be seen as a westminster drama or sort
of some episode of a political version
of love island this is really about the
fact that in the face of these huge
pressures whether that's energy bills
inflation food prices we simply haven't
got a government that is acting and the
only thing i would disagree with with
what concerned femi's themselves have
said about boris johnson is look he
didn't become this person overnight or
at the weekend they knew who they were
getting when they appointed him they
knew how his government would be just
think back to how many of these things
we've had this is the this might have
been the straw that has broken the
camel's back but we've had
a scandal after scandal issue after
issue and i'm afraid they do share some
responsibility for putting him in power
and tolerating this for so long and
actually for the cabinet the majority of
the cabinet i know now i think one in
ten of the government have resigned but
that's still a lot of conservative mps
propping them up and it's our job to
hold them accountable for that which we
will do but the the non-functioning of
the government is directly related to
the problems households and individuals
are facing and that's what we'll be
reminding those conservative colleagues
of because people frankly deserve a lot
better than this
jonathan reynolds labour mp uh john
stevenson conservative mp and christine
jardin from the liberal democrats thank
you all so much for talking us through
uh what your thoughts are on today ahead
of prime minister's questions let's
bring in our political editor now though
beth rigby who joins us now from
westminster
beth this is a really perilous time for
the prime minister isn't it
jane it really is we were talking last
night about hopes fading fast that he
can survive and the question now move
into how long will he survive uh that
process has accelerated dramatically
this morning with the resignations not
of junior back carriers if you like
ministerial aides but serious ministers
and ministers of state he's lost john
glenn from the treasury he's just lost
victoria aitkins from the ministry of
justice he's lost will quince a minister
for children and families that were sent
out to defend boris johnson
but two days ago he's now had 16
resignations from his government
ministers of state two cabinet ministers
the 1922 committee are meeting tonight
to discuss the possibility of changing
the rules and i think it's very likely
today that a delegation could be sent to
the prime minister to say your time's up
either resign or we will try to force
you out i think really the issue is that
he is completely now out of control of
these events the party is moving uh
ministers who have been loyal are moving
and it's not just ministers either jane
it's back benchers too some of the
loyalists back ventures the die hards
people like lee anderson
who always supported the prime minister
or jonathan gullis
now saying that they cannot in good
conscience continue to support him that
also happened with robert howe from the
very influential uh back bench uh
backbencher who chairs a select
committee so really uh the party is now
in free fall uh he might try to hold on
i mean one mp said to me today he has a
choice he can
agree to an orderly succession as
theresa may did after she survived a
confidence vote and then a few weeks
later was tapped on the shoulder and
said the party has lost confidence in
you do you want to face another vote or
resign she chose to revive resign or
boris johnson could choose to hunker
down and fight out that bit of it is
unclear but i think what is becoming
clearer with these resignations is that
a challenge will be coming in somewhere
and other because his government is in
free fall and ultimately if you can't
control your party if you can't keep
ministers in post you cannot run a
government and you cannot run the
country
and beth just looking at these images
now from the commons uh obviously the
opposition bench is packed to the
gunnels that that you know to be
expected
the conservative side's half empty is
that just because uh it's a bit early
we've got 10 minutes for everybody to
get in uh or or do you think that this
is what it's going to look like look
we've got 10 minutes for people to get
in and i'm sure that the whips are
trying to corral mps to come in but but
one mp and i should say this is a an
arch enemy of the prime minister so in
that context uh told me earlier that
last night when there was a meeting
of uh supporters of boris johnson only
about 45 mps turned up that's what this
person said uh and they said very few
back benches were there indeed just a
handful of backbenchers and you can see
the support visibly draining away it was
slightly less clear last night because
following those shock resignations of
sajid javid as health secretary followed
by rishi sunak as chancellor in in
succession then the question was were
other cabinet ministers going to go
there were talk talk about therese
coffee with shigo the work and pension
secretary what about michael gove would
he stand down nadim zahawi he was
actually promoted actually to chancellor
but then
most of the cabinet came out in support
of the prime minister so in a way they
shored him up but that hasn't stopped
the bleed in fact the dam has burst and
you've seen that overnight into the
morning with resignations beginning i
think it was before half eight and
carrying on right up to prime minister's
questions so the prime minister is
completely out of control of events
today it was but a week ago slightly
longer actually where i was in rwanda
with him and we were asking the prime
minister do you want to serve another
term he was talking about potentially
going into the 2030s he was so resolute
that he was not standing down regardless
of the by-election losses regardless of
the difficulties the resignation of his
ethics adviser lord guyt and it seems
that this matter over chris pinscher and
his handling of it having sent people
out to say he wasn't aware for only to
emerge that he was told of a specific
complaint against chris pincher a formal
complaint back in 2019 when he was
foreign secretary it just seems like
that was the straw that broke the
camel's back and once two very senior
cabinet ministers go it starts the
snowball effect which we are now seeing
play out and the question is what on
earth is he going to say today how is he
going to be i would imagine knowing him
a little bit seeing how he
he handles is that he will come out uh
bold and fighting but when he looks
behind him will the benches be full or
will there be more people on those
benches on those government benches
thinking that it's time also to resign
from his administration
they are starting to fill out beth as we
speak uh let's return to john stevenson
conservative mp for carlisle who's
joining us uh head of prime minister's
questions and we got cut off just before
because the prime minister came out as i
asked you the question but i just
wondered who you think if the prime
minister were to go today that the party
would unite behind and how quickly could
that process happen
well i think there would be a number of
candidates that would put their names
forward but i think the 1922 committee
would want to move very quickly to make
sure that there's not a vacuum that
lasts a particularly long time
because it's not in the interests of the
country and nor the party or parliament
so i think the 1922 committee would be
looking to act very quickly but that
depends on what the prime minister
decides to do and we'll have to see what
he does at pmq's today he's meant to be
beating the liaison committee later this
afternoon and we'll have to wait and see
if there are further resignations but
this seemed to be the seeping away of um
power from the prime minister as we're
seeing further resignations of junior
ministers and we'll have to wait and see
if they're further ones from the cabinet
but i think i'm gonna sit on the 1922
committee myself i do think we have a
responsibility that if and when the
prime minister does uh resign or is
removed that we do move quickly to make
sure that the succession happens in a
sensible and timely manner
who would you like to see in charge
well we'll have to wait and see what
happens and who puts our names forward
for a start but i think we're getting
ahead of ourselves right now i think
we've got to wait and see what the prime
minister does and what decisions he
makes during the course of today
we've just got another name to add to
our growing list
of people who are not supporting the
prime minister simon phel has called for
the prime minister to go he is another
mp who has said that he doesn't think
the prime minister should continue in
his job we've had 28 resignations in
total but of course a lot more people
who are withdrawing their support or who
are calling on the prime minister to go
christine jardin from liberal democrats
is still with us on the line also
christine is there anything good that
can come out of this do you do you think
the focus of politics for a very long
time has been focused on things like
sleaze that there has been much less
focus on actually getting politics done
some would argue
do you think that were the prime
minister to go that that would actually
change
i would hope so i would hope that um if
boris johnson goes then we would see a
change from the government because the
government have been getting a lot of
things wrong they haven't been dealing
with the cost of living crisis and they
haven't been dealing with the the energy
prices and the way that the public would
have wanted and i think a lot of
conservative voters have felt let down
betrayed by these governments why
they've lost so many so many
by-elections in their own seats and why
we won so um uh decisively in uh
diverting and huntington recently but
you know it has to change
the whole government the whole direction
of government which does come from the
prime minister has not been effective
the home office is barely fit for
purpose at the moment with the length of
cues for you know waiting for passports
driving licenses as well and
you know asylum seekers
visas everything is grinding to halt and
the government is in danger of being
incapable of governing so what we really
need in this country now is change and
if boris john's going facilitates that
change then that would be a good thing
but it's a mess and it has done nobody
any credit particularly in the
conservative party that they have let it
go on for so long and the time has come
when it has to stop
let's return to our political editor
beth rigby and beth what is happening
right now the prime minister we saw him
leave downing street he drove down to
the houses of parliament he went in uh
through uh the portico there
he has gathered in a room with his
advisors one would assume very close to
to the uh
to the the commons there
what will be happening what
conversations will be being had do you
think
well he'll be preparing for prime
minister's questions and he will see
this as an opportunity to come out
fighting i would imagine and to try and
corral his benches to stick by him he
has been boosted by the fact that so
many cabinet ministers did come out last
night and pledge support
but where he is struggling is it doesn't
detract from the fact that three cabinet
ministers have resigned and now he is
just getting endless resignations uh we
i think we're up to 16 or perhaps 17 of
junior ministerial aides trade envoys
are now ministers of states saying he
can't carry on
so he will be prepping uh for this pmq's
but i'm really interested to see how
does he approach it does he send a
message to his backbenchers i'm not
going anywhere you're gonna have to
force me out also uh what will
backbenchers say to him will we have
another david davis moment do you
remember that a few months ago where
david davis stood up and said in forgot
you know in god's name go he told the
prime minister to resign will other mps
stand up
in the commons and and tell him it's
time for him to go to his face tell him
on the floor of the house we will then
after uh pmqs have the resignation
statement of sajid javid the health
secretary and that will be an electric
moment as well he was the first person
to resign from cabinet the cabinet
minister if you like to wield the knife
around um the pincher issue uh oliver
dowden did resign a week before as party
chair but number 10 were able in a way
to explain that away um but from the
by-election losses because he resigned
on the back of those two devastating
by-election losses so sajid javid will
make this statement straight after pmq's
then the prime minister has to go to the
liaison committee where he'll be grilled
by mps for a couple of hours and after
all of that the 22 committee will meet
tonight and at that point they will
discuss potentially the changing of
rules
and what they do next and in amidst all
of that the question now i have is
whether or not mps will approach the
prime minister today and say look the
letters are in or the majority of the
party the backbenchers no longer uh
support you that's a very fluid uh
discussion that is fast moving sir
graham brady the chair of the 22
committee he's the person that makes
that call because he's the one that
takes the soundings of back benches but
will that happen today it really is a
very fast moving set of events but i
think the principle that we discussed on
the news than the 10 o'clock news last
night that this was a prime minister in
free fall out of control and the
question is now moving from can he
survive to how long he survives you are
seeing that now playing out in real time
as his
his government government ministers and
party members openly desert and defy him
and and we are seeing that all all the
benches filling up beth certainly no
empty benches behind the prime minister
briefly john stevenson conservative mp
back to you for a final thought before
the prime minister takes to his feet
simon fell a fellow cumbrian mp is is
one of the ones who has just uh tweeted
that enough is enough i i wonder what
you think you know the impact is on on
mps it is one thing isn't it having
losing faith in your leader but when you
see your colleagues also losing faith it
just it speeds up that that ball rolling
down the hill doesn't it
well undoubtedly and somebody like simon
fellow is a very sensible individual
moderate member of parliament when
people like him are sort of saying this
is the end of the road i think you've
got to
you know believe that it actually is i
think the conservative party now we want
to
uh see the prime minister i would like
to see him resign later today and then
we have to move on we still have two and
a half years of this parliament to run
we still have plenty that we can do and
i think what we need to do is create a
certainty more a stable government get
behind a new leader and take the country
forward because there's some challenges
for the country and which we all are
aware of but we need stable strong
competent government and that's what i
think the conservative mps now want to
see happen
prime minister has just walked in to the
house of commons prime minister's
questions is due to start imminently
beth if the prime minister were to
decide to go today would he announce it
before prime minister's questions
i wouldn't expect that jane and i
actually um
you know all the soundings that i have
had from those around him from his
allies is that the prime minister has no
intention of resigning that he would
want to carry on i guess there will be a
calculation within his inner team about
at some point whether he can carry on
this is the piece of the jigsaw that
really is uh unknown at the moment which
is what is the process in which he might
resign the prime minister's about to
take to his feet let's listen in
thank you mr speaker today is a big day
as we implement the biggest tax cut
as we implement the biggest tax cut for
a decade
increasing national insurance thresholds
to make tax lower and the tax burden
easier these changes will benefit 30
million people across the uk
and i'm pleased to say that two of those
people are seated here in the public
gallery today
mandy banfield and alan calzari a
typical worker will now save 330 pounds
per year with 70 of employees better off
as a result that is real money for real
people and mr speaker i'm sure the house
will also join me in wishing the best of
luck
to england and northern ireland who are
competing in the uefa women's euro 2022
tournament
which starts today and i'm sure they
will both make the nation proud this
morning mr speaker i had meetings with
ministerial colleagues and others
in addition
in addition to my duties in this house i
i expect i shall have further such
meetings later today then you
thank you sir
last week we launched a new approach to
combating knife crime in milton keys
which means
increased use of stop and search means
tougher charging and custody
tougher sentencing faster youth
diversion and more work with parents and
communities would the prime minister
agree with me that if you carry a knife
in milton keynes you should expect to
end up behind bars
i thank my honourable friend what he's
doing to campaign for tougher sentences
in uh milton in milton's campaign
against knife crime and as a result of
the uh of what the conservatives have
done adults who are convicted of certain
offences involving a knife including
threatening with a knife or a second
defense of possession face a minimum
sentence of six months imprisonment mr
speaker and guess who voted against
tougher sentences for life crime
we know
we now come to the leader of the
opposition here's dharma
uh thank you mr speaker today is the
start of the women's euros and i know
the whole house will wish the lionesses
the very best of luck in bringing
football home
mr speaker
it's also
mr speaker
it's also been 40 years since the death
of terence higgins
terence worked at hansard by day and
heaven by night before he sadly died of
aids
the labour party and the terence higgin
trust are committed to ending new cases
of hiv by 2030.
together we can
mr speaker last week a government
minister was accused of sexually
assaulting a young man
i want to quote the victim's account
he says
he grabbed my ass
and then he slowly moved his hand
down in front of my groin
i froze
i accept that's not easy listening
but it's a reminder to all those
propping up this prime minister
just how serious the situation is
he knew
the accused minister had previously
committed predatory behavior but he
promoted him to a position of power
anyway
why
mr speaker that individual the uh on
member for tamworth no longer has the
conservative whip he no longer has a job
he is no longer as soon as i was made
aware of the allegation that he has just
read out mr speaker the complaint that
was made uh he lost uh his um he lost
his status as a conservative mp and he
is now the subject uh mr speaker of uh
an independent investigation to the uh
complaints and grievances uh panel and
that is entirely right i want to say to
him uh mr speaker i want to say to him
that i abort uh bullying and abuse of
power anywhere in parliament in this
party or in any
party
you
other
us none of that explains why he promoted
him in the first place
and we've heard it all before
we know who he really is
before he was found out he's reported to
have said
he's handsy
that's the problem
pincher by name
pincher by nature
now has the prime minister ever said
words to that effect and i'm not asking
for bluster and half truth we've all had
enough of that
yes or no
i'm minister mr speaker i'm not going to
trivialize uh what happened uh i i i
know yes mr speaker yes mr speaker
i'm not because the very serious
complaints have been raised against uh
the member for tamworth and they're now
being investigated mr speaker it is true
it is true that the complaint was uh
raised when he was in the foreign office
and the matter was uh resolved it's
absolutely true it's absolutely true mr
speaker that it was raised with me i
greatly regret that he continued uh in
office and and i i've said that i have
said that before mr speaker i have said
that uh before mr speaker but it is now
it is now the subject of an independent
investigation and and that is the right
thing mr speaker
frankly i think the people of this
country i would like also to hear they
would like also to hear about uh other
jobs that are held by people in this
country not least the 500 000 people
we've got off welfare into work uh in
the last six months alone mr speaker
those are things that are making
differences to the lives of people up
and down the country and i'm proud of it
no one's hearing that no denial
and he says the matter was resolved when
he means it was upheld exactly and
they're all sitting there as if this is
normal behavior
when that young man reported his attack
to a government whip
she asked him
if he was gay
when he said that he was
she replied
that doesn't make it straightforward
that comment will sicken anyone who's
experienced sexual assault and then be
made to feel like they somehow ask for
it or who worry that prejudice means
their complaint won't be taken seriously
will he apologize for those disgraceful
comments on behalf of his government
speaker i've i i've already said uh that
i regret very much that uh the
member for tamworth continued to hold
office after the complaint was made
against him in the in the foreign office
and uh it was it was resolved in the
foreign office his apology was accepted
but clearly that was not enough any
hindsight mr speaker i should have
realized that he would not she would he
would not change however when it came to
the friday of last week and when i uh
was given the information that uh he's
read out about the complaint that was
made against uh the honourable member i
acted immediately mr speaker and i i
took the whip away from him and we will
not tolerate we will not tolerate that
kind of behavior in this or any other
party mr speaker and what we also want
to do is to help people up and down the
country with the things that also matter
to them like cutting their taxes mr
speaker by 330 pounds this year which is
what we're doing here
doesn't that just sum him up awful
behavior unacceptable in any walk of
life it's there for all to see but he
ignores it
it was the same when his ally was on the
take from the lobbyists
it was the same when his home secretary
was bullying staff
it was the same when taxpayers money was
being abused and it was the same when he
and his mates parted their way through
lockdown
anyone quitting now
after defending all that hasn't got a
shred of integrity
mr speaker isn't this the first recorded
case of the sinking ships fleeing the
rats
[Applause]
he talks he talks about
he he should hear what he's not saying
about him
he talks about he talks about in
integrity and he wanted he wanted to
install uh the member for islington
north into number 10 right and mr
speaker that's what that's what he
wanted to do imagine imagine what our
country and what the world would be like
now
he talks about integrity he voted he
voted 48 times to overturn the will of
the british people and take us back into
the european union and by the way
listening to his muddled speech the
other day that is exactly what he would
do again uh mr speaker
he talks about integrity but mr speaker
he has voted time and time again against
against sanctions on criminals that
would put them behind bars this is the
government that is tough on
i'm sorry he's he talks about integrity
he is himself facing a criminal
investigation and mr speaker which he
asked me to resign
what a pathetic spectacle the the dying
act of his political career is to parrot
that nonsense
and as for those who are left
only in office because no one else is
prepared to debase themselves any longer
the charge of the lightweight brigade
have some self-respect
mr speaker for a week
he's had them defending his decision to
promote a sexual predator
every day the lines he's forced them to
take have been untrue
first that he was unaware of any
allegation
untrue
then he was unaware of any specific
allegation
untrue
then he was unaware of any serious
specific allegation
and now he wants them to go out
and say
that he simply
forgot
but his whip was a sexual predator
anyone with anything about them would be
long gone from his front bed
[Applause]
in the middle of a crisis doesn't the
country deserve better than a zed list
cast of nodding dogs
well mr speaker uh it's when it's
exactly when
when times are tough when the country
faces pressures on
the economy
and pressures on their budgets mr
speaker and when we have the biggest war
in europe for 80 years mr speaker that
is when that is exactly the moment that
you'd expect a government uh to continue
with its work not to walk away uh mr
speaker and to get on with our job and
to focus on the things that matter to
the people of this country and that so
we're not only cutting taxes uh today mr
speaker we're putting 1200 pounds into
every of one of the eight million most
vulnerable households in the country mr
speaker thanks to the strength of our
economy and thanks to the decisions that
we took mr speaker which he opposed at
the time
[Applause]
the only thing he's delivering is chaos
i started this session with a quote from
the young victim in all this how he
froze when he was attacked
when i was prosecuting rapists i heard
that from victims all the time
victims said they froze
because it's not about sex
it's about power
and the power the disgraced government
minister had was handed to him by that
prime minister
and he's only in power because he's been
propped up for months by a corrupted
party defending the indefensible
so it's no longer a case about swapping
the person at the top isn't it clear the
only way the country can get the fresh
start it deserves is by getting rid of a
lot of them
mr speaker
the difference
the difference between this
we've got to get through premises
questions prime minister
mr speaker the difference between this
government and that opposition is we
have a plan and they do not
and we're getting on it they want to
focus on this type of issue mr speaker
we're going to get on with our jobs
we're going to control prices mr speaker
by not giving in to the union barons
they're paid by the union barons and
they're and they're proud of it
we were the first european country to
arm the ukrainians mr speaker i'm proud
of that and those guys mr speaker that
the party opposite the party opposite
not only did they want to put corbett
and mr corbin into number 10 uh the
memphis into north but eight of them
including the shadow foreign secretary
the shadow deputy leader
six others six others voted to get rid
of our independent nuclear deterrent and
mr speaker today we are cutting taxes
we're helping half a million people into
work and thanks to the strength of our
economy we're helping people up and down
the country and we are going to continue
to deliver on the mandate i was given
johnny mercer yeah yeah
yeah thank you very much mr speaker on
monday nights the northern ireland
legacy bill reached its third reading
and so with it the beginning of the end
of the journey a long journey to make
sure the service and sacrifice of those
who served in iraq afghanistan and now
northern ireland is not re-risen by
those who seek only to line their own
pockets but would the prime minister
agree with me that never again
can we allow such a gulf to open up
between this place and those who serve
never again must they be made to feel
like we are not on their side and will
he redouble his commitment to make sure
this is the best country in the world to
serve in the military and be a veteran
all their family yeah
my honourable friend very much i thank
you for all the work that he's done uh
for veterans and continues to do this
bill will give veterans the certainty uh
they deserve and uh were fulfilling at
the manifesto pledge to end the cycle of
investigations but also at the same time
making sure that families can get the
answers they need about what happened to
their loved ones we now come to the
leader of the snp in blackfoot
thank you mr speaker and can i give
every best wish to the england and
northern ireland uh ladies football team
as they
approach the euro championship there's
nothing better than seeing your teams in
these finals can we also commemorate the
passing 40 years ago of terence higgins
and all those that have died from aids
and i'm sure mr speaker the whole house
will want to join with me in passing
condolences to the family of friends of
the scottish football goalkeeping legend
andy gorham who sadly passed far too
early last weekend he will long live in
the memory of the best goalkeeper that
many of us have seen
mr speaker
it's easy to forget that only 10 days
ago
the prime minister was dreaming of a
third term
mr speaker
you know
it's often said that a week is a long
time in politics but it turns out that
10 days is truly a lifetime
because let's face it it's a minor
miracle that the prime minister has even
made it through to
prime minister's questions and he really
ought to see the faces behind him
because prime minister it really is over
the prime minister
is desperately clinging on to his own
fantasy but the public can't afford to
put up with this first of a government a
minute longer
today
we should be talking about the tory
costs of living crisis soaring inflation
and the growing cost of brexit
but instead
it's always
it's always about him
how many more ministers
need to quit
before he finally picks up his pen
and writes his own resignation letter
perhaps that's what he's doing now
actually actually mr speaker i was just
jotting down some notes on it on his
question which i thought was excellent
when he was talking about the economy uh
because that is the issue that is the
country uh faces and that is the and
that is where this government is
introducing i think the most important
search helping countries are helping uh
families up and down the country uh with
1200 pounds uh going into their bank
accounts uh right now cutting taxes for
30 million people 330 pound tax cut and
helping half a million people into work
through the way to work scheme that is a
fantastic thing to be getting on and
doing that is the priority of this
government and that's what i'm going to
focus on i'm glad he i'm glad he likes
it
in blackfoot my goodness
nothing to see we should all move on if
we live in the world
prime minister you know a few weeks ago
i compared the prime minister to monty
python's black knight
actually turns out i was wrong
he's actually the dead pirate
whether he knows it or not he's now an
ex-prime minister
he will leave behind two deeply damaging
legacies
i hope the dishonesty of his leadership
follows him out of the downing street
door but the other legacy is that of
brexit
and that will stay
because i'm sad to say
that the labour party now fully supports
mr speaker
scotland wants a different future
not just a different prime minister
so if the prime minister won't resign
will he call a general election and
allows scotland the choice of an
independent future
free from the control of westminster
prime minister mr speaker i i noticed
that his remark that the labour party
given up on uh on returning your opinion
was not greeted with rapture by the
benches opposite that's because it's not
it's not true uh they want to go back in
uh just as he does i think that's a that
is a that is a terrible mistake it would
be anti-democratic mr speaker and as for
the referendum uh that he wants well we
had one of them as i've told him before
uh in 2014. come on
thank you mr speaker does the prime
minister think there are any
circumstances in which he should resign
[Applause]
i think mr speaker uh clearly if the uh
if there were circumstances in which i
felt it was uh impossible for the
government to go on and discharge
the mandate uh that we've been given uh
or if i felt for instance that we were
being frustrated in our desire to
support the ukrainian people uh or or
over some major point uh then i would
but but frankly mr speaker the job of a
prime minister in difficult
circumstances when he's been handed a
colossal mandate is to keep going and
that's what i'm going to do
there's several roberts
[Music]
there you have there you have it mr
speaker
once again the prime minister he puts
political survival before public duty
but people can see
even if he goes
it's not on if it's a when isn't it
the same westminster arrogance will
continue to dictate our futures in wales
does he want a medal for being the best
recruiting sergeant for independence we
could wish for yeah
[Applause]
actually mr speaker ever i look around
the united kingdom i i had a great talk
with mark drakeford uh the other day uh
as well as talking to nicolas sturgeon i
see the bonds of our union uh being
strengthened the whole time and uh and
and i'm confident that they will uh they
will get they will continue to do so
linked
thank you very much thank you mr speaker
uh
the government's town center leveling up
funds have been very successful around
the country but there are a few town
centres like waterlooville in neon
valley that are in desperate desperate
streets and haven't managed to get any
funding in getting a scheme into the
present round of funding
can my right honourable friend assure me
that future funds will be available to
help declining high streets become fit
for the 21st century and survive the
post-pandemic yeah
i thank my honourable friend and she's a
great champion for for me on valley and
i'll make sure that she gets a meeting
with the minister for leveling up at the
earliest opportunity
[Applause]
thank you mr speaker the public clearly
thinks that this government has lost the
plot over the cost of living crisis so
the prime minister may be aware that the
average salary for a nurse is 36 000 for
a primary teacher it is 38 000 pounds
they and indeed working people
everywhere are struggling to pay their
rents and their mortgages
given they
can barely afford a 150 000 pound
mortgage on a new home can he tell this
house how he could afford a 150 000
pound tree house
uh well what i can tell him mr speaker
uh is that up and down the country
rather than talking about fantasy
infrastructure i can talk about real
infrastructure uh we are helping to
unite and level up the people of this
country with 650 billion pounds of
investment helping people helping to
lift the aspirations and opportunities
of people up and down the country and
it's thanks to the strength of our
economy we're helping exactly the people
he describes with 1200 pounds going into
their bank accounts uh to help them with
the cost of living pressures under the
house of baltimore
the prime minister knows
that while he's prime minister i want to
do all the good he can
why is prime minister's green and
present land can i refer to edm 108.2
about the goring gap the chatsmall farm
or to the department of
leveling up the land above goring
station the farm in worthing which was
fully protected and will be fully
protected with another inspector says
that worthy council protecting it will
happen can i ask him to tell the
government to withdraw their objection
to worthy council's appeal against the
absurd decision by a planning inspector
to allow 482 homes to go on this green
lung between goring and ferry
[Applause]
i i thank i thank the right honourable
very much and uh and he campaigns uh on
this issue for some time i will make
sure that he gets a meeting with the uh
with the relevant minister to discuss uh
the uh the development in going by sea
in they agree thank you thank you mr
speaker on the 21st of january the
government
committed a hundred million pounds from
the automotive transformation fund to
british rule to a gigafactory in my
constituency callus warns back and as of
today prime minister not a penny not a
single happening is being received by
the the company and
it jeopardizes up to 8 000 much needed
jobs
the tensions between the prime minister
and the former chancellor have sadly now
being much exposed and i'm telling you
prime minister the betrayal of my
constituents cannot be another broken
promise if there's government prime
minister
prime minister
give him a node
instruct your new bestie to make sure
that the check is in the post this
afternoon because who knows
who knows he'll be in that seat this
time this afternoon never mind next week
can i congratulate the honourable
gentleman on the passion with which he
advocates investment in uh in british
fault and i like i totally share i share
his uh his uh enthusiasm and actually i
want to thank uh my honourable friend
remember from uh for blithe valley as
well uh who is a heroic uh heroic
campaigner on this issue i can tell him
that the letter was sent last night uh
mr speaker uh an in principal offer of
support for this project uh through uh
uh how about that hang on in there mr
speaker that's what i'm going to do
thank you mr speaker
the world is facing a global food crisis
in which the
poorest nations face catastrophic
consequences
will the prime minister take all
possible action to negotiate and
facilitate access to the grain source
stranded in ukraine
we have a limited opportunity to avert
famine in developing nations and the uk
must play its full part using all the
resources at our disposal
uh my my right on the phone is
completely right and there are 25
million tonnes of wheat that are
basically being held hostage by uh by
putin uh that's equivalent to the annual
consumption of many uh of the least
developed countries and uh we're helping
to uh lift that blockade uh
not just by negotiation but also by
supplying uh demining equipment uh
insurance for the uh the commercial
ships uh that might be involved and also
10 million to help improve the railway
infrastructure that would be necessary
to get the grain out by rail
mark
mr speaker yesterday the prime minister
said that he is fed up for people
saying things on his behalf
it's not just him that's fed up saw the
british people and his ministers who are
resigning
they're sick of time and time again
being sent out by him to say things that
aren't true
it's a real problem him or them for
believing him in the first place
mr speaker i i i thank him very much and
look i want to be clear what i what i
want to say is uh i i i i say it again
uh i
regret the way the uh appointment
happened and i i was clear with the
house about uh what i knew at the time
but i want to stress that i take this
matter extremely seriously i i i'm very
sorry for the uh the impact it's had on
on the victims but the individual in
question the member for tamworth is now
subject to uh an independent complaints
and grievance uh procedure as soon as as
soon as soon as that as soon as that
began as soon as that complaint was made
i should say mr speaker uh the whip was
taken away
can i just say we don't know that is the
case it is confidential and i think
we've got to stop referring to something
that we don't know that and i want to
put the house unnoticed that we don't
mention it teresa villas
just over a fortnight ago two horrific
fatal stabbings took place in a quiet
street in east barnet
with the metropolitan police now in
special measures for the first time in
its history will the prime minister urge
the mayor of london to start living up
to his responsibilities
the man needs to get a grip on crime you
need to give barney's fair share of
nuances
and he needs to abandon his plans when
are you going to do something about it
yeah well i i do notice mr speaker that
crime has spiked since the previous uh
mayor of london
and and it is the labour party either
voted against uh stop and search uh mr
speaker that voted against increased
funding for the police and i think as
for the labour mayor he'd be do better
to get out of california and take
control of crime in his city
according to the nhs confederation not a
single one of the so-called 40 new
hospitals the prime minister promised at
the last election will be built by 2024.
two of those new hospitals are in my
constituency hammersmith opened in 1902
and sharon cross opened in 1818
they're not new hospitals and there's no
building going on like all his promises
they exist only in his warped
imagination as this is likely to be his
last prime minister's questions will he
finally tell us the truth
well actually mr speaker if he looks at
what we promised and what we delivered
uh we said we'd get 20 000 police out on
the streets we've actually got 13 000 uh
500 more already already we said we do
50 000 more nurses we're already on
track and he's quite wrong about the
pledge on hospitals we're going to
deliver them by 2030 mr speaker that was
always clear and the only reason we can
do that is because we're putting the
funding into our nhs which he and his
party opposed gary sanbrook thank you
very much mr speaker um yesterday in an
attempt to boost morale in the tea room
the prime minister said uh a table but
there were seven people mps in the
carlton club last week and one of them
should have tried to intervene to stop
chris from drinking so much as if that
wasn't insulting enough to the people
who did try and intervene that night and
then also to the victims that drink was
the problem isn't it the example mr
speaker but if the prime minister
constantly tries to deflect from the
issue always tries to blame other people
for mistakes and that at least nothing
um left for him to do other than to take
responsibility and resign
[Applause]
can i just say you want to be
embarrassed by clapping this is not a
debate
mr esterson it's not debating society
this is
this is prime minister's questions i
want to get through the questions
there's other people want to catch my
eye and the way to do it is not by
clapping prime minister mr speaker
there's a very simple reason why they
want me out and that is and that is and
that is because
and that is because they know mr speaker
uh that i think that otherwise we are
going to get on and deliver our mandate
and win another general election and
that is the reality mr speaker lyra
wilson
thank you very much mr speaker
the prime minister once wrote
it is a wonderful and necessary fact of
political biology that we never know
when our time is up
long after it is obvious to everyone
that we are goners we continue to
believe our duty
is to hang on to the perks and
privileges of our posts in reality we
are just terrified of the come down
yep
so for the sake of this great country
will the prime minister heed the advice
of his former senator england get over
his terror and do the decent thing
mr speaker
i refer the honorable ladies the answer
i have just given when when things are
tough of course people uh turn their
fire on the leader of the the country
but it is my job to get on and deliver
uh our manifesto which we are and to
deliver on the mandate uh on which i was
elected and to get this country uh
through tough times just as we got it
through coven and that is what i'm going
to do
field of bruce
mr speaker
around a thousand
i apologize around a thousand delegates
from a hundred countries are at the
freedom of religion or belief
international ministerial conference
over at the qe2 yeah yeah yeah
there is still time for honourable
members to visit
but will the prime minister agree with
you that this significant conference
will count for nothing unless it results
in concerted global action to promote
and protect freedom of religion or
belief around the world
[Music]
[Applause]
i i thank her very much and freedom of
religion and belief is integral to
people's
identity and their uh their sense of
themselves and their and their own
personal uh free and security and i
thank her for the work she's uh doing as
my own envoy on that subject and also
for the wonderful conference that she
has uh that she has organized it was
great to talk to her about it yesterday
thank you very much mr speaker will the
prime minister join me in expressing my
deepest condolences to those injured and
affected by the explosion at a block of
flats at redwood grove in bradford on
monday
which has sadly led to the death of one
resident with others yet to be accounted
for this is a timely reminder of the
dangerous work undertaken by the fire
service so will the prime minister join
me in praising the emergency services
who were at the scene and also
reconsider his two percent
pay offer when firefighters have endured
a real terms fair cuts of 12
over the last decade yeah yeah
uh i i thank him very much and as he uh
and i shared very much his support for
the firefighters of our country they did
an incredible job and overall it's a
testament to their work that uh deaths
from fire uh over a long period of on
average been uh decreasing thanks to the
work that they uh they put in we will do
our best to look at the public sector
pay review uh body offer and do our best
to fund them as as much as we can but
everybody knows the inflationary
pressures that this country is now under
we don't want to have pay increases that
are simply swallowed by price increases
david johnson very much mr speaker the
north morton in my constituency was
dubbed britain's kindest village because
this 160 wait for it
[Applause]
because this 160 home village committed
to take 50 ukrainian refugees
it has more wisdom now um in the gallery
today there is a group of those hosts
and some of the ukrainians that they are
hosting including two young people who
hope to go into ukrainian politics in
the future
will my honorable friend join me in
welcoming them to this place and in
thanking north moulton for their efforts
i thank him very much for what he's
doing to
to host uh young uh ukrainians thank
everybody actually in this house who's
looking after ukrainians i think a lot
of people
are doing that and can i say i believe
it's the wish of this entire house uh
that those young people should grow up
to live in a free independent democratic
and sovereign ukraine it's a doubt thank
you mr speaker given that the prime
minister doesn't like walkouts and
strikes
what legislation will he be introducing
to stop further walkouts and strikes
amongst his cabinet colleagues
[Applause]
mr speaker i think that uh the whole
house would have observed the brilliant
performance on the radio this morning by
the the new chancellor
of the exchequer
and
that's no disrespect to the old to the
former chancellor of the exchequer uh
but and what i think it shows mr speaker
is that in common with many sectors of
the of the uk economy uh there is a
ready supply of skilled labor uh in the
upper reaches uh in the upper reaches of
the conservative party
davis
hey davis uh thank you mr speaker i'd
like to draw the prime minister's
attention to the words he used in
response to my rightful friend remember
worthing uh when he asked the question
earlier
six months ago i called on the prime
minister to resign because even then
it was clear that his approach to
leadership and integrity was already
creating a pipeline of problems that
would paralyze proper government
today i ask him to do the honorable
thing to put the interests of the nation
before his own interest
and before in in his own words it does
become impossible for government to do
his job
prime minister i i thank him very much
for
the point that he's he's made he's made
again well i've just got it i respect i
just i just couldn't uh disagree with
him more uh look at look at what the
government is doing today uh cutting
taxes uh for 30 million people
we've just we've just completed a
program to get half a million people off
welfare into work mr speaker thanks to
the strength of our economy thanks to
the position uh that we're now in which
was which was because of decisions that
we took that they opposed and this will
never forget never forget we have that
we are able to give 1200 pounds uh to 8
million of the poorest and most
vulnerable families in this in this
country that is the right thing to do
we're getting on with it
and we will continue with our active and
energetic program for the benefit of
this country uniting and leveling up and
unleashing the prosperity of the entire
nation
final question five bets
the local government association has
told us that over 400 families who've
come to this country from ukraine under
the family scheme have subsequently
presented themselves as homeless to
local authorities because the
authorities haven't got enough
accommodation those people are going to
end up in temporary accommodation
there's a simple answer
local authorities could be allowed to
contact the many thousands of people who
volunteered to provide homes under the
homes for ukraine scheme the problem is
the government doesn't allow families to
transfer from the family scheme to the
home scheme when will the prime minister
act to ensure people have come thousands
of miles of this country aren't placed
in temporary accommodation but we take
on the generosity of those families who
are willing to offer them a home
uh i i thank you very much for the very
valuable point that he's raised and uh
we'll make sure that uh uh families are
able to cross over from one uh scheme to
to another uh
and to simplify and speed up the process
but i don't think that should take away
mr speaker from the generosity of this
country in in welcoming ukrainian
ukrainians 135 000 visas have so far
been issued through our uncapped scheme
both the family scheme and the homes for
ukraine scheme uh it's changing the
lives of those ukrainians and i think we
should all be proud of what we are doing
we now come to the personal statement
i call sanji javit
mr speaker i'm grateful for your
permission to make this statement
yesterday we began our day together you
i my right old friend the prime minister
and members from right across this house
when we broke bread together at the
parliamentary prayer breakfast
and we listened all of us to the words
of reverend les isaac who spoke about
the fact that responsibility that comes
with leadership
the responsibility to serve the
interests of others above your own
and to seek common ground of your party
your community and above all
your country
my colleagues will be forgiven for my
sense of deja vu
despite what it might seem
i am not one of life's quitters
i didn't quit when i was told that boys
like me don't do maths
i didn't quit when old school bankers
said i didn't have the right school ties
and i didn't quit
when people in my community said that i
should not marry the love of my life
i care deeply about public service
and giving back to this country that has
given me so much
that is why
when i got the call from my radable
friend the prime minister just over a
year ago i didn't hesitate to serve
again
it was a critical time for our country
tough decisions needed to be made about
when we were going to come out of
lockdown about supporting the national
health service and the care sector under
unprecedented stream
it has been an absolute privilege of my
life to have been trusted with these
responsibilities
and i can only hope
that my best has been good enough
it has undoubtedly also been one of the
toughest roles that i've had so far
the gravity of home office decisions
the scale of treasury decisions
but nothing matters more
than the health of your people of the
british people especially
and in the wake of a pandemic
caring for people's health and
well-being is truly a noble vocation and
so i would like to take this opportunity
to pay tribute to all of those
across the country working in health and
care sectors as well as those that i
worked so closely with in my old
department dhsc and in the nhs
there's so much that i planned for the
long term for the long-term reform of
our health and care systems
and it is a wrench to leave that
important work behind
now when i last gave a personal
statement from this seat
i spoke about the importance of
institutions and conventions
today it is about the importance of
integrity
and don't worry there's not gonna be a
series of these
institutions and integrity
are both central pillars that underpin
our great democracy
it doesn't matter what your political
perspective is
in this house i believe that we are all
motivated by the national interest
and that the public expects us all all
of us to maintain honesty and to
maintain integrity in whatever we do
this is not an abstract matter
we've seen in great democracies
what happens when divisions are
entrenched and not bridged
we cannot allow that to happen here we
must bring the country together as one
nation
effective governance inevitably requires
loyalty and collective responsibility of
course it does and i'm instinctively a
team player and i have completely
focused on governing effectively over
the last year
but treading the tightrope between
loyalty and integrity
has become impossible in recent months
and mr speaker i will never risk losing
my integrity
i also believe a team is as good as its
team captain
and that a captain is as good as his or
her team
so loyalty must go both ways
the events of recent months have made it
increasingly difficult to be in that
team
it's not fair
on ministerial colleagues to go out
every morning defending lines that don't
stand up and don't hold up it's not fair
on my parliamentary colleagues who bear
the brunt of constituents dismay in
their inboxes and on their doorsteps in
recent elections
and it's not fair
on conservative members and voters who
rightly expect better standards from the
party they supported
when the first stories of parties in
downing street emerged late last year
i was personally assured at the most
senior level
by my white olive friends then team
that and i quote
there had been no parties in downing
street and no rules were broken
so i gave the benefit of that
and i went on those media rounds to say
that i'd had those assurances
from the senior most senior level of the
prime minister's team
then we had more stories
we had the sue gray report
a new downing street team
i continued to give the benefit of the
doubt
and now this week again
we have reason to question the truth and
integrity of what we've all been told
and at some point
we have to conclude
that enough is enough
i believe that point is now
i welcome the prime minister's public
acknowledgement last night that matters
could have been handled better in who he
appointed
and what was said about what he knew
when
and i appreciated his kind and humble
words and his humble spirit when i went
to see him yesterday and also the kind
letter that he has sent to me but i do
fear that the reset button can only work
so many times
there's only so many times
you can turn that machine on and off
before you realize that something is
fundamentally wrong
last month
i gave the benefit of doubt one last
time
but i haven't concluded that the problem
starts at the top
that is not going to change
i have concluded that the problem starts
at the top and i believe that is not
going to change and that
means that it is for those of us in a
position who have responsibility to make
that change
i wish my cabinet colleagues well and i
i can see they have decided to remain in
the cabinet
they will have their own reasons
but it is
it is a choice
i know
just how difficult that choice is
but let's be clear
not doing something is an active
decision
i'm deeply concerned
about how the next generation will see
the conservative party on our current
course
our reputation
after 12 years in government depends on
regaining the public's trust
this is not just a personal matter the
philosophy and perception of
conservatives depends on it
it is central to the conservative ideal
that we believe in decency
in personal responsibility and in social
justice enabled by conventions and the
rule of law
the conservative mission to extend
freedom and prosperity and opportunity
is all at risk if we cannot uphold that
ideal yeah
and mr speaker it is not
only the the conservative party is not
the only great institution in need of
urgent repair
like everyone in this house i have been
dismayed by the drip grip of stories of
harassment and worse by members of this
house
so i'm also concerned about how the next
generation will see this house and the
health of our democracy
in recent years trust in our roles has
been undermined through a series of
scandals
but the one thing
we can control
is our own values and behaviors
so it is incumbent on all of us
to set high standards for ourselves
and to take action when they are not met
by others
mr speaker i'm grateful for the messages
of support that i've had from many
members of this house and beyond
i got into politics to do something
not to be somebody
so it is hard in one way but not in
another
being a good father
a husband a son and a citizen
is good enough for me
and if i can continue to contribute to
public life and my party from the back
benches
it will be a privilege to do so
can i say to the host there will be no
more personal statements today
[Music]
[Applause]
well a very powerful statement there
from sanjid javid concluding that he
went into politics to do something
rather than be somebody
saying that he had given
his colleagues downing street and the
prime minister the benefit of the doubt
several times over the past
but that at some point we have to
conclude that enough is enough
and that time is now he spoke about it
being all about integrity and that he
had concluded that the problem starts at
the top and that is not going to change
trust in our roles has been undermined
he said the one thing that we can
control are our own values and our own
behaviors and for that reason he said he
has resigned he said that the
institutions and integrity underpin our
great democracy and the treading the
titrate between loyalty and integrity
has become impossible
in recent months so that there the
former health secretary sergey javid's
statement on his resignation yesterday
from the government and that of course
following uh prime minister's questions
a tricky prime minister's questions for
the prime minister during that time
there were two resignations
of mp stuart anderson and joe churchill
both resigned during that half an hour
the prime minister's questions was on
he was challenged by kia stammer about
his behavior and about why he had not
done more to protect members of staff
and then there were two conservative mps
three conservative mps actually david
davis gary sandbrook and tim lowton who
all called on him to resign he said that
he will not resign he said that hanging
on in there is what i am going to do
when things are tough it is my job to
hang on
well can he hang on we will certainly
find out he's going to be grilled by mps
at three o'clock this afternoon the
liaison committee is going to question
him about all manner of things
we know that the 1922 back bench
committee is also going to be meeting to
decide its new leaders over the course
of the day so pressure on the prime
minister by no means uh has disappeared
as a result of that performance in prime
minister's questions
one reminder that so if you read we'll
bring you all the latest live from
westminster later on today on the take
this evening with top guests in analysis
live on sky news at nine o'clock later
today uh but in the meantime let's talk
to our political editor beth rigby beth
what did you make of the prime
minister's performance and prime
minister's questions
well jane it was brutal in the commons
today the prime minister as we expected
uh was clear that he was not going
anywhere that he intends uh to stick at
it and fight on but you saw
the faces
on the front bench absolutely abject
misery and actually at these moments
when the end feels like it is coming and
that is what it feels like now for boris
johnson
it feels in that chamber quite vicious
and brutal and kierstama was vicious i
thought in some of his comments he
called
the prime minister he called his
behavior a pathetic spectacle i think it
was and he said uh that these were the
dying days uh of his government he then
uh widened that attack uh to boris
johnson's cabinet calling them the zed
list of nodding dogs it was just
uncomfortable and brutal and for boris
johnson the fire wasn't just coming from
kierstarma there were three mps uh in
the chamber that called on him to resign
david david saying do the honorable
thing and go gary sanbrook who is on the
executive of the 22 the people that have
it in their gift to change the rules on
leadership elections
was absolutely brutal to the prime
minister accusing him of blaming other
mps at that event
with chris pincher on wednesday night
last week at the carlton cup asking them
why they hadn't stopped chris pincher
something some mps said tipped many over
the edge and gary sandbrook using the
chamber there to bluntly put that to the
prime minister and call him out on it
the prime minister responding i am
carrying
on and then after all of that theatre
all of that drama
uh sajid javid uh stood up and he was
the one following the resignation of
oliver dowden a week ago that really
triggered this run of resignations last
night as he became the first cabinet
minister uh last night to resign quickly
followed by the
former chancellor now rishi sanak who's
not making a statement today but sajid
javid in that comment there he said i
went into politics to do something not
to be some body and he said the problem
starts at the top i'm just going to try
and find the exact statement i wrote it
down let me give you a sec
he said
i gave the prime minister the benefit of
the doubt one last time but i've
concluded the problem starts at the top
and it is not going to change he then
went on to say he had a position of
responsibility
and as a cabinet minister he felt it was
his responsibility to try and make that
change acknowledging that other cabinet
ministers hadn't followed him out of the
door but even as he was speaking there
was another resignation this time the
housing minister a housing minister
let me just get it up stuart andrew he
resigned i think that takes the tally to
now
18 ministerial uh resignations be it
ministerial cabinet minister ministerial
age other junior post but 18
resignations uh since 6 pm last night
this government in free fall and the
prime minister they're fighting on but
my goodness he and he he might not have
looked beaten but his benches certainly
did
they did didn't they they bet but it was
interesting looking at the demeanor on
the prime minister's face during um
that speech there from sanjay javid
we're going to bring in
anderson sorry beth my apologies uh
we'll reflect on that a little bit later
but let's talk to one of the
conservatives who've come out today to
say they no longer have faith in boris
johnson that is lee anderson mr anderson
the mp for ashfield
why did you feel that now was the time
to leave
well i think over the past two years
since since he's been the prime minister
uh since well since i've been here you
know he's doing a great job you know
through got brexit done uh served us
well through the pandemic and i think
it's been superb during the ukrainian
war but the events of the last week
uh are just not acceptable in any walk
of life and and sadly i mean i think i
think boris has been like i say i've got
a lot of respect for him he's a good man
but sadly over the past week he's been
found wanting number 10 has been found
wanting and and and i cannot honestly
look at myself in the mirror
and put up with this sort of behavior in
this place our my constituents deserve
better and the people of this country
deserve better so i'm sorry but you know
i've withdrawn my support
do you think that the prime minister has
got the message i mean clearly during
prime minister's questions we saw
difficult questions for him for from
three conservative mps who had all of
these resignations but he seems very
bullish doesn't he he says that hanging
on when the times are tough is what he
does
he does i mean it's more than the prime
minister it's about the team that's
around him as well the advisors all the
staff in number 10 but you know the book
stops with the pm and i just think he's
been let down um but you know he's made
mistakes himself like i said i think
he's a good man i feel you know i'm not
not happy about the situation i feel
like i've
betrayed him a little bit but at the end
of the day you know my duties to my
constituents to my party to the party
members and to people of this great
country and it's just so sad it's so sad
that this ended like this
you say it was a hard decision and you
feel you've betrayed him you must have
wrestled with this overnight
well yeah wrestle with my conscience i
mean i think he's a good man i think the
boss is a good manager he's done good
things he got me my job here this is
this is like you know dumping it dumping
on the member of your family it's not
it's not an easy thing to do but at the
end of the day
you've got to do what the right thing is
and i think it's the right thing to come
out and say you know enough enough you
know we have people working this place
that work around mps the social life of
mps and we see the actions of last week
where where a uh where a minister was
promoted when we actually you know
number 10 knew what was going on in the
past they sort of swept under the carpet
we can't do that it's just it's just not
acceptable and i couldn't live with
myself if i said nothing you know i've
got nothing to lose here i'm not a
minister
i don't want a career here i just want
to be the mp for ashfield and serve my
my constituents you know i can come out
fighting which is what which is what i
have done um and i wish to boss all the
best and i just wish i had not got to
this if i'm honest
what do you think the 1922 committee
should do now do you think that they
should
go to him and say look enough is enough
well i mean i mean that's they've got
that power to do that and i think they i
think they meet him on the boss this
afternoon i don't know what they're
going to say i'm not in any clicks or
groups here that's part of any any
conspiracies i just keep myself to
myself if they go and do that so but
something needs to change
you say you're not part of any cliques
or groups and and it's interesting isn't
it that we've seen the resignations and
the the letters like your own people
saying that they're withdrawing their
support have come from a really wide
range across different elements of the
conservative party and certainly across
different ministerial departments for
you it seems like a very very personal
decision rather than something that's
motivated politically or or by any
conversations you've had
well mine's definitely a personal
decision maybe other people other people
has resigned it is part of a bigger
picture i don't know you have to speak
to them about that but mine's a purely
personal decision i believe i'm the only
red wall mp at the moment that's come
out like this so you know i don't know
what's going on this afternoon it's uh
it's not it's not happy times here but
you know my conscience is clear and i
think my moral compass is pointing in
the right direction
do you think he'll be gone by the end of
the day
no i don't
you don't you don't think he'll resign
lee ashfield anderson ashfield mp really
good to talk to you thank you very much
thanks for joining us sir he is one of
those who has withdrawn his support from
the prime minister
[Music]
good afternoon this is sky news at one
live from downing street on a day of
resignations and revolt in westminster
so far this afternoon eight more people
have quit as others withdraw support but
in the last few minutes a major moment
in the commons as sajid javed who quit
as health secretary last night delivered
stinging criticism of his former boss
spreading the tightrope between loyalty
and integrity
has become impossible in recent months
and mr speaker i will never risk losing
my integrity
sinking ships fleeing the rat the labour
leader accuses boris johnson of losing
all integrity amid fresh calls from both
sides for him to resign
in the middle of a crisis doesn't the
country deserve better than a zed list
cast of nodding dogs
eight further resignations today as more
conservatives withdraw their support for
the prime minister warning that they'll
no longer pirouette around fractured
values
nadine zahawi promises a big pay rise
for teachers and hints at tax cuts we'll
hear from the new chancellor
sajid javid and also rishi sunak both
questioned the integrity of this prime
minister do you think this prime
minister has integrity i do i think he
no we need to know well because he's
determined to deliver for this country
sky news will bring you all the
developments throughout the day as the
prime minister fights to stay in downing
street ahead of another big questioning
from mps later this afternoon
[Music]
hello good afternoon this is sky news at
one live from downing street on a day of
resignations and revolt in westminster
so far this afternoon eight more people
have quit as others withdraw their
support for the prime minister following
last night's bombshell resignations and
in the last few minutes a major moment
in the commons assadjid javed who quit
as health secretary yesterday
delivered this stinging criticism of his
former boss yesterday we began our day
together you i my right old friend the
prime minister and members from right
across this house when we broke bread
together at the parliamentary prayer
breakfast
and we listened all of us to the words
of reverend les isaac who spoke about
the fact that responsibility that comes
with leadership
the responsibility to serve the
interests of others above your own
and to seek common ground of your party
your community and above all
your country
my colleagues will be forgiven for my
sense of deja vu
despite what it might seem
i am not one of life's quitters i didn't
quit when i was told that boys like me
don't do maths
i didn't quit when old school bankers
said i didn't have the right school ties
and i didn't quit
when people in my community said that i
should not marry the love of my life
i care deeply about public service
and giving back to this country that has
given me so much
that is why
when i got the call from my radable
friend the prime minister just over a
year ago i didn't hesitate to serve
again
it was a critical time for our country
tough decisions needed to be made about
when we were going to come out of
lockdown about supporting the national
health service and the care sector under
unprecedented strain
it has been an absolute privilege of my
life to have been trusted with these
responsibilities
and i can only hope
that my best has been good enough
it has undoubtedly also been one of the
toughest roles that i've had so far
the gravity of home office decisions
the scale of treasury decisions
but nothing matters more
than the health of your people of the
british people especially
and in the wake of a pandemic
caring for people's health and
well-being is truly a noble vocation and
so i would like to take this opportunity
to pay tribute to all of those
across the country working in health and
care sectors as well as those that i
worked so closely with in my old
department dhsc
and in the nhs
there's so much that i planned for the
long term for the long-term reform of
our health and care systems
and it is a wrench to leave that
important work behind
now when i last gave a personal
statement from this seat
i spoke about the importance of
institutions and conventions
today it is about the importance of
integrity
and don't worry there's not gonna be a
series of these
institutions and integrity
are both central pillars that underpin
our great democracy
it doesn't matter what your political
perspective is
in this house
i believe that we are all motivated by
the national interest
and that the public expects us all all
of us to maintain honesty and to
maintain integrity in whatever we do
this is not an abstract matter
we've seen in great democracies
what happens when divisions are
entrenched and not bridged
we cannot allow that to happen here we
must bring the country together as one
nation
effective governance inevitably requires
loyalty and collective responsibility of
course it does and i'm instinctively a
team player and i have completely
focused on governing effectively over
the last year
but treading the tightrope between
loyalty and integrity
has become impossible in recent months
and mr speaker i will never risk losing
my integrity
also believe a team is as good as its
team captain
and that a captain is as good as his or
her team
so loyalty must go both ways
the events of recent months have made it
increasingly difficult to be in that
team
it's not fair
on ministerial colleagues to go out
every morning defending lines that don't
stand up and don't hold up
it's not fair on my parliamentary
colleagues who bear the brunt of
constituents dismay in their inboxes and
on their doorsteps in recent elections
and it's not fair
on conservative members and voters who
rightly expect better standards from the
party they supported
when the first stories of parties in
downing street emerged late last year
i was personally assured at the most
senior level
by my white old friends then team
that and i quote
there had been no parties in downing
street and no rules were broken
so i gave the benefit of that
and i went on those media rounds to say
that i'd had those assurances
from the senior most senior level of the
prime minister's team
then we had more stories
we had the sue grey report
a new downing street team
i continued to give the benefit of the
doubt
and now this week again
we have reason to question the truth and
integrity of what we've all been told
and at some point
we have to conclude
that enough is enough
i believe that point is now
i welcome the prime minister's public
acknowledgement last night that matters
could have been handled better in who he
appointed and what was said about what
he knew when
and i appreciated his kind and humble
words and his humble spirit when i went
to see him yesterday and also the kind
letter that he has sent to me
but i do fear that the reset button can
only work so many times
there's only so many times
you can turn that machine on and off
before you realize that something is
fundamentally wrong
last month
i gave the benefit of doubt one last
time
but i haven't concluded that the problem
starts at the top
that is not going to change
i have concluded that the problem starts
at the top and i believe that is not
going to change and that's
means that it is for those of us in a
position who have responsibility to make
that change
i wish my cabinet colleagues well and i
i can see they have decided to remain in
the cabinet
they will have their own reasons
but it is
it is a choice
i know
just how difficult that choice is
but let's be clear
not doing something is an active
decision
i'm deeply concerned
about how the next generation will see
the conservative party on our current
course
our reputation
after 12 years in government depends on
regaining the public's trust
this is not just a personal matter the
philosophy and perception of
conservatives depends on it
it is central to the conservative ideal
that we believe in decency
in personal responsibility and in social
justice enabled by conventions and the
rule of law the conservative mission to
extend freedom and prosperity and
opportunity is all at risk if we cannot
uphold that ideal yeah
and mr speaker
it is not
only the
conservative party is not the only great
institution in need of urgent repair
like everyone in this house i have been
dismayed by the drip grip of stories of
harassment and worse by members of this
house
so i'm also concerned about how the next
generation will see this house and the
health of our democracy
in recent years trust in our roles has
been undermined through a series of
scandals
but the one thing
we can control
is our own values and behaviors
so it is incumbent on all of us
to set high standards for ourselves
and to take action when they are not met
by others
mr speaker i'm grateful for the messages
of support that i've had from many
members of this house and beyond
i got into politics to do something
not to be somebody
so it is hard in one way but not in
another
being a good father
a husband a son and a citizen
is good enough for me
and if i can continue to contribute to
public life and my party from the back
benches
it would be a privilege to do so
can i
say java there making his statement to
the house after resigning yesterday well
the former health secretary statement
came after an unsurprisingly bruising
prime minister's questions for boris
johnson the labour leader sama pulled no
punches when it came to describing him
and also the secretaries of state who
remain in this cabinet
awful behaviour unacceptable in any walk
of life it's there for all to see but he
ignores it
it was the same when his ally was on the
take from the lobbyists
it was the same when his home secretary
was bullying staff
it was the same when taxpayers money was
being abused and it was the same when he
and his mates parted their way through
lockdown
anyone quitting now
after defending all that hasn't got a
shred of integrity
speaker isn't this the first recorded
case of the sinking ships fleeing the
rats
[Applause]
he talks he talks about
he he should hear what he's not saying
about him uh mr speaker he he talks
about he talks about in integrity and he
wanted he wanted to install uh the
member for islington north into number
10 right and mr speaker that's what
that's what he wanted to do imagine
imagine what our country and what the
world would be like now
he talks about integrity he voted he
voted 48 times to overturn the will of
the british people and take us back into
the european union and by the way
listening to his muddled speech the
other day that is exactly what he would
do again uh mr speaker
he talks about
integrity but mr speaker he has voted
time and time again against against
sanctions on criminals that would put
them behind bars this is the government
that is tough
i'm sorry he's he talks about integrity
he is himself facing a criminal
investigation mr speaker which he asked
me to resign
what a pathetic spectacle the the dying
act of his political career is to parrot
that nonsense
and as for those who are left
only in office because no one else is
prepared to debase themselves any longer
the charge of the lightweight brigade
have some self-respect
mr speaker
for a week
he's had them defending his decision to
promote a sexual predator
every day the lines he's forced them to
take have been untrue
that he was unaware of any allegation
untrue
then he was unaware of any specific
allegation
untrue
then he was unaware of any serious
specific allegation
and now he wants them to go out
and say that he simply
forgot
but his whip was a sexual predator
anyone with anything about them would be
long gone from his front bench
in the middle of a crisis doesn't the
country deserve better than a zed list
cast of nodding dogs
well during prime minister's questions
today the conservative mp tim lowton
also had a question for the prime
minister about the recent controversy
does the prime minister think there are
any circumstances in which he should
[Applause]
resign i i think mr speaker uh clearly
if the uh if there were circumstances in
which i felt it was uh impossible for
the government to go on and discharge uh
the mandate uh that we've been given uh
or if i felt for instance that we're
being frustrated in our desire to
support the ukrainian people uh or or
over some major point uh then i would
but but frankly mr speaker the job of a
prime minister in difficult
circumstances when he's been handed a
colossal mandate is to keep going and
that's what i'm going to do
[Applause]
another conservative mp gary sanbrook
was also critical of boris johnson
yesterday in an attempt to boost morale
in the tea room the prime minister said
a table but there were seven people mps
in the carlton club last week and one of
them should have tried to intervene to
stop chris from drinking so much
as if that wasn't insulting enough to
the people who did try and intervene
that night and then also to the victims
that drink was the problem isn't it the
example mr speaker but is the prime
minister constantly trying to deflect
from the issue always tries to blame
other people for mistakes and that at
least nothing
left for him to do other than to take
responsibility and resign
well as we woke up this morning there
were more resignations from boris
johnson's government
it began with the departure of laura
trott she wrote on facebook i have
resigned from my role as parliamentary
private secretary to the department of
transport
trust in politics is and must always be
of the upmost importance but sadly in
recent months this has been lost
she was followed by the children's
minister will quince who wrote on
twitter with great sadness and regret i
have this morning tendered my
resignation to the prime minister after
i accepted and repeated assurances on
monday to the media which have now been
found to be inaccurate
well sky news was one of the media
organizations he spoke to on monday and
this is what he told us at the time
i spoke with number 10 both yesterday
and today and i i asked them firmly and
clearly for an answer on this and i've
been given categorical assurance that
the prime minister was not aware of any
serious specific allegation with regards
to the former deputy chief whitman
more resignations followed with more
letters explaining why people felt the
need to leave their government posts a
notable one was from the justice
minister victoria atkins
she wrote in her letter
values such as integrity decency respect
and professionalism should matter to us
all i have watched with growing concern
as those values have fractured under
your leadership i've given you the
benefit of the doubt at each turn
i can no longer pirouette around our
fractured values we can and must be
better than this
well the total of resignations today now
stands at eight the most recent is the
housing minister stuart andrew who
posted his letter on twitter
he said there comes a time when you have
to look at your own personal integrity
and that time is now
therefore given recent events i have no
other choice than to resign
well as well as resignations there have
been four letters from mps withdrawing
their support from the prime minister
one of them was lee anderson who i spoke
to not long ago and who explained that
it was not an easy decision
this is like you know dumping dumping on
a member of your family it's not it's
not an easy thing to do but at the end
of the day
you've got to do what the right thing is
and i think it's the right thing to come
out and say you know enough's enough you
know we have people working this place
that work around mps the social life of
mps and we see the actions of last week
where where a uh where a minister was
promoted when we actually
you know number 10 knew what was going
on in the past it sort of swept under
the carpet
we can't do that it's just it's just not
acceptable and i couldn't live with
myself if i said nothing you know i've
got nothing to lose here i'm not a
minister
i don't want a career here i just want
to be the mp for ashfield and serve my
my constituents you know i can come out
fighting which is what which is what i
have done
and i wish to boss all the best and i
just wish i had not got to this if i'm
honest
well let's talk to our political editor
beth rigby uh not an easy prime
minister's questions for the prime
minister beth and the day is not going
to get any easier is it
jane it really isn't we were talking
last night about the way in which those
two cabinet resignations of sajid javid
and rishi sanak blew open this simmering
tory civil war
over boris johnson we are now in open
warfare we're reaching a crescendo
perhaps the end game
and it's becoming increasingly vicious
and brutal and ugly as you get to
that point
some people fighting to get boris
johnson out and a prime minister
desperately clinging on and fighting for
his own survival and what we're seeing
in westminster today is this playing out
blow
by blow and you saw it viscerally on the
floor of the commons there today what
did we get we had kierstarma
being mocking being vicious in his
attacks not just on johnson but on the
wider cabinet of the prime minister he
described the performance at pram hughes
as a dying act and a pathetic spectacle
and he also sought to humiliate the
wider cabinet for sticking by boris
johnson saying have some reself respect
as he called them the zeal the list
of nodding dogs and then if that wasn't
enough you had three
uh conservative mps standing up
in the commons there
so we're playing
oh sorry i could hear i could hear sound
there so i thought we would jump into
kierstama we're not we've just got
picture so then you had three uh
conservative
mps uh all calling for his resignation
in the commons none more brutal than
gary sanbrook who is on the 1922
executive
committee
and he was very very critical of the
prime minister calling him out and
publicly accusing the prime minister of
going to the tea room and criticizing
other mps at that event with chris
pincher on wednesday night last week at
the carlton club where uh the former
deputy chief wit was accused of groping
two victims for which he has resigned
and now there is an investigation
underway gary sanbrooks called the prime
minister out for he said the prime
minister blaming the mps for not trying
to stop uh mr pincher from doing that
and gary sanborn went on to say the
prime minister constantly tries to
deflect from the issue always tries to
blame other people from mistakes there's
nothing left for him to do but to take
responsibility and
resign and then after all of that you
had sadja javid
the former health secretary in a very
dignified and powerful statement there
it had two parts i think one was calling
out
the prime minister not in anger but
rather regret which i think made it more
potent
where he said that recent months have
made it increasingly difficult to be
part of the team it's not fair for
ministerial colleagues to defend lines
that don't stand up it's not fair for
mps having to defend the prime minister
on the doorstep and it's not fair on
conservative supporters and voters that
the government are in this spectacle
that they find themselves he said at the
point you get to the point when enough's
enough that point is now and he went on
to say i've concluded the problem starts
at the top and that is not going to
change he said it was the responsibility
for those in a position to do so to make
that change he also within that
resignation speech was a clear
leadership pitch i think where he uh
described his values he described his
background he talked about integrity he
insisted that he didn't come into
politics to be somebody but to do
something and he couldn't in good
conscience stand and carry on there he
is going into his house last night and
just finally where are we now because
this is moving so quickly we now have 18
uh resignations be that from the cabinet
to all the way through ministers of
states down to some of the most
junior
roles where are we with boris johnson
well he
is as expected intending to fight on
number 10 confirming the pm will fight
any new confidence vote saying that the
prime minister still believes despite
all of this he has the support of the
majority of his mps but what happens now
well what we're getting now uh is
reports and expectation that the 22
committee
could meet uh this afternoon in a
potentially private meeting at 4 p.m
where they discuss whether to change the
rules there's growing expectations mp's
telling me that they think that graham
brady who's the chair of the 22
committee
could now have enough supporters or
enough letters rather into him
calling for the prime minister to go so
there could be a meeting in which
the 22 do decide the executive to change
the rules and bring forward that
confidence vote that's a very live issue
and that's what the focus will be on
this afternoon it is getting very
ugly
in
westminster today as the prime minister
tries to hang on and his opponents
become far more forceful now in trying
to push him out
beth thanks very much for that analysis
for now and as both are saying later in
the day boris johnson will appear before
the parliamentary liaison committee as
he fights to stay in this job due to
start answering questions at three
o'clock this afternoon so stay with us
for that for full live coverage and all
the analysis
afterwards well as we heard at the start
of the program there was a major moment
in the commons this afternoon as sajid
javid gave his resignation speech he
delivered stinging criticism with his
former boss watching on saying that
treading the tightrope between loyalty
and integrity has become impossible in
recent months uh all this it's now from
sanji java's constituency in bronze
grove in worcestershire it's sky
correspondent becky johnson and becky if
there was a moral high ground to take
sanji java definitely took it today
didn't he what are people
there voters who voted for him saying
about the events of the last couple of
days
well we've spent the day here and i have
to say i've heard pretty much every
opinion there could be a real real range
of opinions here in bronze grove on uh
sergeant javid also on boris johnson
whether satya javid did the right thing
of course it was his resignation that
kickstarted this wave of resignations
let's chat to some of these constituents
we've got martin and michelle here
who've been debating uh the finer points
of what's been going on so so that's
what a point so
sergey javid saying enough is enough
reset button needs to be pressed well it
can only work so many times problem
starts the top it's not going to change
michelle what do you think about what
sagittar javit has said and what do you
think about boris johnson
boris johnson is a buffoon i just have
no time for the man whatsoever with
regards to sadid as a business owner in
bronze grove i do think
he's absolutely correct he's on the
money and the sooner boris goes the
better are you a conservative voter
i'm not no so what would you like to see
happen next
well i would like to see boris obviously
move down because it's not tannable
tenable and
for
somebody with some honesty
and
some common sense and somebody who is
going to listen to the
you know
the general public and take on board the
crisis we are heading in there are
businesses who are going under daily
at the moment that is fact that is fact
i'm a publisher of a local community
magazine and i've already had three
businesses
that now are no longer in business just
in the last six weeks
what was it or at what point did you
lose confidence in boris johnson well
from day one really i've never been a
fan of um boris johnson and genuinely i
think
that
we need to
get rid of him
and
you know who knows sajid might make the
top man yeah now martin another business
owner here in brumsgrove i know you
don't quite agree with your friend
michelle what do you think about boris
johnson's future she charges too much
and if somebody came in like sajid she
might lower her prices for my
advertising
what what do you make about the future
of the prime minister especially after
what sahaja yoga has said this if forest
goes then we want sanji i don't know
what so what did sajid say this one so i
haven't seen that yet well he he talked
about how he'd been given assurances for
example that there hadn't been parties
at downing street
he then had to go out and defend the
prime minister he talked about not being
able to tread the line between loyalty
and integrity what do you make the fact
that he's very honest and
he's very driven and
i think he'd be brilliant at the top
poor old boris uh he's just misread
every step of the way
it's a shame because i was quite a fan
of his but sanji david has said the
problems start at the top that's the
conclusion he's reached so should boris
johnson stay
yeah i think he's going to go whatever
we say even if i want him to say he's
going
uh it's a time thing now i think he's in
a matter of weeks at the most do you
like the man i like the guy because a
he's very intelligent
or he's got no foresight but apart from
that very intelligent guy
very highly educated because of
himself against other people at the same
age he was always number one
london mayor he didn't do a bad job of
that i agree
and his career has been quite good so i
just think the times covey and
everything else he's just got on top of
him and uh muddled him up a bit perhaps
he should start drinking jack daniels or
something like you know and he might
then do it other whiskeys thank you so
much for chatting to us
is definitely um top draw so i think
we're happy with him thank you very much
well yes so you heard there and actually
a lot of people supporting sajid javi
but there is actually i have spoken to
people here who think that boris johnson
should stay in his job but as you can
hear a whole range of opinions here in
bromsgrove it is actually the main topic
of conversation as people are having
their lunch here
becky thanks very much becky johnson for
us there and bronze grove well let's uh
move a bit closer to where i am now
outside number 10 and just go down to
parliament central lobby our deputy
political editor sam coates is there uh
sam so many conversations happening
before prime minister's questions what's
the the feeling what are people saying
now that that's over and we've heard
this personal statement as well
well jane there's no underestimating it
to say that there is just a sense of
proper crisis at the moment i don't
think we're in a phase where you have
functioning government i think that
you're in a phase
of british politics where we have huge
uncertainty about whether boris
johnson's uh going to make it to recess
maybe even uh whether he's going to make
it out uh the week um i've had a lot of
conversations with tory mps and they are
all agreed to one thing that compared to
36 hours ago the mood amongst
conservative mps has completely shifted
those who were sitting on the fence
those who thought that time wasn't right
to change leader those who didn't want
to do the difficult thing maybe change
some rules in order to drag boris
johnson from office all of them
almost every single person i've talked
to now
says that there has been a step change
in people's opinions but it's one thing
telling journalists behind the scenes
and in private it is another thing to
actually act and as far as i can tell
there are two different uh
work streams as it were amongst the
rebels there is one set of suggestions
that could put the cabinet front and
center now many of the cabinets are
loyalists but there still are some
people perhaps figures like michael go
who could go to the prime minister with
our within hours and say look your time
is up now he would be wary of doing that
given his history with boris johnson
2016 stabbing him in the in the front in
the leadership contest nevertheless
michael gove amongst the people i am
told who is weighing up what to do the
leveling up secretary uh considering
whether or not to lead maybe even a
delegation of cabinet ministers
the second beneath that in within
government uh we are expecting more
resignations there are over 100 members
of any government there are bricks
coming out of the wall all over the
place ultimately if boris johnson isn't
able to
rebuild that wall then the government
will fall
because it will be quite obvious he
doesn't have enough mps on his side to
do that and as he said in prime
minister's questions if it becomes
really clear he can't govern then he
will go so that's one set of reasons why
boris johnson might go from office the
other
is to do with the wider parliamentary
party there is a meeting at four o'clock
today of the 1922 executive and then the
meeting of all tory mps uh who formed
part of the 1922 at five now there is a
suggestion that maybe rules could change
as early as today although uh some think
that after internal elections next week
that timing is more likely so we could
see uh the button being pressed as soon
as today on rule changes that would
allow another vote of no confidence and
if that looks likely maybe graham brady
the chairman of the 1922 committee goes
himself to the prime minister warns of
of what's about to happen basically says
you can go in your own time in a manner
of your choosing in a dignified way or
you can choose to fight this out and i
can tell you i've had enough sandings
from colleagues
and you will lose so those are the two
areas the two ways in which there is
enormous titanic pressure raining down
on boris johnson let's just unpick uh
right now with a conservative mp exactly
what they think is going to happen over
the coming uh hours uh and potentially
days andrew morrison uh joins me
now let's start with the 1922 committee
there's this meeting of tory mps later
today at five o'clock what are you
expecting could we get a change of the
rules that would allow another vote of
no confidence in boris johnson literally
a matter of hours or days well we could
do actually it's up to the existing
executive there's elections for the
executive imminently and suggesting that
there'll be a state of candidates
for
a real change um i think we've passed
that down i think the mood in the house
is such that even the existing executive
will probably decide that it's necessary
to change the rules in order to force
this and you've detected the movement
today there's a palpable sense that we
will cross the rubicon and that this is
endgame now and the important thing is
that boris johnson departs in a
decorative fashion
accepting the roles for his achievements
over the past couple of years
it departs nevertheless so to be
absolutely clear
at five o'clock today
graham brady chairman of the 1922
committee could
stand up in front of tory mps and say
that they have already decided to change
the rules to allow another vote of no
confidence in boris johnson and that
could take place as soon as tomorrow or
next week and that he's going to go to
boris johnson to warn him of this and
give him the option either of fighting
or a dignified exit is that what you're
saying yes um but if you recall he
didn't have to change
theresa may he simply had to say that
that was a strong possibility if she
didn't move on at that time so i think
it's just the threat of it and the
inevitability
can you just explain for viewers
watching perhaps bewildered
why the mood has shifted so dramatically
in just 48 hours because of the
resignation that somebody probably
hadn't heard of doing a job they
probably didn't know about and yet we've
got this situation where
three weeks ago the party was behind him
majority of the buzzer runs and now it
looks like they're not how how has this
happened well i think the majority of
backbenchers weren't behind the prime
minister because 148 if you see most of
the payroll voted for
vote of their confidence that means the
bulk of the backpackers were not and
that's a problem for any prime minister
i think the res the uh the letter from
uh lord yesterday to the college which
stands very important for many of us
within the westminster village
might have prompted some ministerial
resignations it was certainly
influential in me resigning to trading
for example uh given your donald status
as an ex
permanent secretary in the foreign
office where i used to work but now
we've had that drip drip of ministerial
resignations what appears to me to be a
damage this morning and people resigning
all over the place
that i think is something that's going
to continue the course of the day and
see how boris can actually form the
government at this rate because he won't
have enough credible people to plug
those gaps we're hearing figures like
michael gave potentially weighing up
going to the prime minister and saying
look graham brady could be knocking your
door later the time
it's already turned already up what
would you say to michael g would you
urge him to do that well michael has
previous in this matter remember the
events of 2016 and michael's role in
that he's a very significant individual
he's a big beast in the tory firmament i
think if he were to go knocking on doors
it would have a big impact
thank you very much indeed uh andrew uh
so jane there we have it action possibly
today
uh great thanks very much for that sam
we're here in the last few minutes three
more resignations uh mp
slain saxby has resigned as well as two
parliamentary private secretaries as
well so that takes the number of those
who've resigned uh over the last 24
hours to 21 now
well one can only imagine what's been
going on behind those doors behind me
over the last 24 hours or so as boris
johnson's teams uh try to mitigate and
contain the damage we're joined now by
jonathan haslam who is former downing
street communications director uh john
major's time uh jonathan good to talk to
you today um
in terms of what has happened over the
last week it's clear that there is a
prime minister who has a fairly loose
relationship with the truth and doesn't
seem to have a particularly good memory
either but but how much of what has gone
wrong could can you lay the blame of his
advisers and those involved in the media
operation here at downing street
well good afternoon jane uh clearly they
do have a significant problem and
as sergeant javid said in the house of
commons this afternoon it really stems
from the top you have to take your lead
from your leader
and so if he is telling his director of
communications and the press office one
thing and they are dutifully reporting
it and they're not checking sufficiently
then they have a significant problem and
it seems as though there isn't
sufficient challenge going on in downing
street and that may well be because of
all of the conflicting interests there
are we have steve barclay who's now the
health secretary
was chief of staff there's david canzini
who is a powerful figure but not a
politician per se
and then gutter harry who is a
communications person who knows johnson
very well indeed
and then there are the ranks of the
civil service as well so it looks like
again a reset which he organized after
uh partygate hasn't really worked in
organizational terms it's chaos and
that's reflective of the nature of boris
johnson so i don't think that's likely
to change and he confirmed it when he
was out in rwanda that if people are
looking for a psychological change in
boris johnson uh don't expect it to
happen because it's not going to happen
so i'm afraid whichever person or group
of people is in charge of the
communications at downing street they're
facing a task of pushing water uphill in
many respects because they can't
necessarily rely upon
what they're being told and in today's
media environment jane as you know
you're outside downing street right now
right rolling news demands almost
instant answers and there's little time
and little forgiveness for making
mistakes and unfortunately for boris
johnson it's more than just making
mistakes there's a whole litany uh
throughout his whole career of playing
fast and loose with the truth there's a
very good reason why when we had the
prorogation of parliament issue and it
went to the supreme court a witness
statement the most usual thing uh that
you would expect from the defendants
wasn't forthcoming because nobody would
sign it that nobody it seems would be
prepared to put their name to that piece
of paper and then you go through the
whole list of other things that have
happened
and the one that has broken the camel's
back i think is this
drip over chris pincher about what the
prime minister knew when
and that has been the most appalling
litany of failures in communications
terms they've got a problem and i think
the thing we're looking for now actually
is the momentum which you are recording
and sam and beth have been telling us
about
and looking at the other aspects of what
the conservative mp was saying a moment
ago about actually who is there to carry
out the business they've lost today john
glenn a long-standing treasury minister
who's very very effective
we've lost stuart andrew now he's about
the 12th housing minister we've had in
10 years and god knows that tells us
something about why housing is a problem
who's going to be number 13.
so boris johnson actually faces a
problem about can he organize a
government to carry out the government's
business
so this is a huge problem for them jane
do you think he can hold on do you think
he can come back from this
it's very difficult to see how you can
with this momentum
you've noted that there are more
resignations coming through albeit at a
junior level but those are the sort of
people you would look to fill some of
the more senior jobs in normal times and
i think it's very hard unless that
momentum is somehow stopped or slowed
down
it's very difficult to see how johnson
gets out of this at the moment and i was
very struck by the dignified and
professional and actually i thought he
was choking back something of
emotion in sanji javid's speech to the
house of commons
his remarks about
coming into politics to do something
rather than to be somebody
play very much to the view that boris
johnson wanted to become prime minister
more as a vanity project than anyone
with a rock-hard philosophical point of
view about what's great for the country
and i think that was very very pointed
and actually the understated way in
which sergey javid
made his remarks was very very powerful
and will live in the memory much longer
than the knockabout that in a sense we
saw in the house of commons i suppose
the other thing we'd learned from uh all
of that was it was interesting to see
how kierstama approached it from the
sexual predator point of view in the
first instance they also learned that he
can't do a payoff line to to save his
life
and from boris johnson we saw the usual
rambustuous stuff
and i was very stuck by some of the very
tart remarks from the back benchers the
gentleman who was talking about those
issues that you found
in the tea rooms where on the one hand
publicly boris johnson can look as
though he is apologetic and he is
responding and on the other hand as soon
as he's away from the cameras and
talking to his backbenchers it's blaming
somebody else
there is a bit of a stench actually of
decay about the whole operation
and the government really does need to
recognize and that's the government the
cabinet at the moment who haven't
declared their hand
about what the british public's making
of this this psycho drama within the
conservative party is holding them back
from the things that boris johnson says
he wants to achieve
but that is you know the great paradox
while he's there they can't do it and
yet the british public faced with the
cost of living crisis
faced with all the difficulties the
fears that are bound from the war in
ukraine
need to be dealt with and we can't do
that while boris johnson is still in
charge
jonathan haslam uh former down street
communications director really good to
talk to you thank you very much for
giving us your thoughts
well just to confirm three resignations
just over in the last five minutes are
all from the most junior positions in
government they are slain saxby uh she
has resigned from defra claire
cutino from the treasury and david
johnson from the department of education
and that brings the total of
resignations since six o'clock last
night now up to 21.
and of course conservative
parliamentarians are not just in the
commons they are in the lords as well
baroness ros altman is a conservative
life peer and the former pensions
minister and she joins us now from north
london and ross altman what do you think
the prime minister should do
i i'm
very sad to conclude that i cannot see
how his position is sustainable
um i think the mood
for most backbenchers
is that this is not something that
can continue the situation has
been
sliding out of control for some time
and we have to restore
trust
honesty
integrity
at the top of government because our
very democracy and freedom depends on it
if you lose trust of the people
your own people never mind
the rest of the population
then
that it becomes impossible to govern
properly and you may make rules but if
everybody thinks well you don't pay the
rules anyway or you know you're not
sticking by the standards that you
expect of everyone else then slowly
slowly over time
it ebbs away at the social structures
that are essential for our democracy and
that's kind of what sajid javid was
was pointing out today you know that
there comes a limit
integrity is vital
uh and and integrity and and reflecting
on what sajid javid said the prime
minister himself though also said that
when times are tough you hang on and
that is his job he doesn't appear to be
inclined to resign does he so what do
you think should happen now
i think that obviously it is up to
conservative mps ultimately
uh if the prime minister
isn't willing to accept and and you know
i'm very sad because
boris johnson is great company he's you
know always able to make people feel
good
but
when you're running a country at tough
times actually
that's not all that counts if if what
you're saying
isn't what's actually happening
then ultimately
you don't solve the problems of the
country you just create false premises
false hopes
and you're not getting to grips with the
real
issues
so you know i think
the 1922 committee
will be making appointments next week
there will be a process in place
to discuss what to do
if the the party has lost confidence
in the leader of course there are people
who still
uh
appreciate boris johnson and all he has
done and and
maybe feel
reluctant to let that go but
it's so dangerous both for the party and
the country
if there isn't a stand made now after
all that we've seen all that we know
all that we hear
do you think the people have been naive
that he has pulled the wool over
people's eyes because as you say he is
great company he is uh funny and
engaging and he certainly managed to get
many people to vote for the conservative
party who had not voted for them in the
past
do you think that some politicians have
perhaps been a little naive in
supporting him all this time
that's possible he's certainly a master
at pulling the wool over people's eyes
he's a master at disguising
what's actually happening by pretending
something else is really happening and
you want to believe it he's he picks up
on what people want to believe and wants
to think
and that's great if you are you know
looking for good company or you need
somebody to cheer you up but if you
actually want to deal with underlying
problems
that doesn't always get you very far it
gets you maybe to the first stage that
everybody's in perhaps the right frame
of mind
to deal with problems but unless you
actually deal with them and that's sort
of what rishi sunak and sajid jabid were
saying and many other
ministers have also concluded
then you do need a change this country
needs
uh trust
and
deep thinking at the top to get us out
of the mess that we're in and clearly
you know these are difficult times
at the last election a lot of people
voted for boris johnson
partly because of his personality partly
because of the fear of jeremy corbyn and
i still
believe that
a corbyn led government would have been
far worse than what we have had so far
especially in the context of russia and
we need a conservative government but we
need a conservative government that
sticks to conservative principles in my
view and this at the moment isn't really
happening
baroness rose altman former pensions
minister and a conservative life peer
thank you very much
thank you
well let's think a little bit more about
what is going on behind the big black
door behind me we're joined by anita
bartang a former conservative special
adviser um
anita what do you imagine is going on
behind that that door today the prime
minister made it very clear during prime
minister's questions that he isn't going
to resign we've had this
really very powerful statement in the in
the commons afterwards from sanji javid
and now we've got the liaison committee
ahead how do they spin this
the prime minister needs to necessarily
spin
the resignation
but he just needs to
underscore his resolve
um it's clear from the speed with which
the prime minister
found alternatives for his cabinet and
that he is determined to maintain his
momentum and i think we'll see a similar
thing with replacements for the
ministers i mean their does get to a
point where there's such a critical mass
that it's not possible um to build those
gaps but remember you've got about 100
or so people on the on the payroll it's
a high number and so far we're talking
about a sort of 10 to 15 percent of that
payroll having resigned thus far so i do
think the prime minister sees little
disadvantage to not um
toughing it out
and so i think that that dynamic will
continue
unless and until there is a significant
vote of no confidence in the prime
minister
but in terms of what is happening inside
number 10
we've spoken to jonathan haslam a while
ago about what happens if a prime
minister doesn't necessarily uh tell the
truth to advisers and and then what
happens if they then don't necessarily
tell the truth to journalists uh it's
very corrosive isn't it in terms of a
working relationship
it is it is i mean advisor advisor
ministers decide boris johnson will be
making
the final call about what he wants to do
but i think if his direction to his team
is
let's find alternatives for the
ministers that have resigned what can i
do in respect of the you know economic
announcement speech that was expected to
be made next week how do i keep that
momentum up what negotiations do i need
to have with nadim zahari over the
proposals that we could put forward to
spell out you know economic
and economic direction that will be
appealing to conservative mps i think
all of those things will be things that
he will be tasking his advisors with
doing because you know the alternative
is to sit and scroll through twitter
which i don't think is in the prime
minister's style
what did you make of his performance in
the house of commons
well i thought that he
definitely decided that he was going to
you know not pretend nothing was
happening but he was going to roll out
his greatest hits and certainly make the
case and underscore
the a number of things that he has
achieved and also underscore his
personal he feels mandate and his
electoral election winning success and i
think all of those will be important
messages to trot out to mps who will
possibly take fright at the possibility
of the uncertainty of a contest and what
that does to the
unity of the conservative party but also
to fears that this may end up at the
ballot box at a moment where the economy
is in an incredibly tough situation not
just inflation we've seen what's been
happening to the pound this morning
which is not just about the prime
minister but actually about those
broader questions around the underlying
strength of the economy so i think the
prime minister did what the only thing
he could do really i think in this
situation which is to say by the way
i've done a great deal and i'm
determined to keep doing more
anita beauty former conservative special
adviser thank you very much
well in the last few minutes it's all
changing we've had another letter of no
confidence this time from robert generic
another mp our deputy political editor
sam coats is in parliament's central
lobby sam how significant is this
intervention
robert jamerick a long marcher alongside
the prime minister he was a cabinet
minister but today he writes i found it
difficult to support this government uh
ever since you started rising tax and
it's painfully clear that you're
providing you're failing we're failing
to provide the coherence grip and
direction the country needs so part of
robert generic's argument is that there
isn't policy direction in government but
part of his argument is that
boris johnson's uh own personal behavior
is costing the party more fundamentally
he writes on his facebook page there has
been a significant and i fear
irretrievable loss of trust with the
public confirmed by the mishandling of
serious allegations in recent days if we
are to continue our present path we wish
during we risk doing lasting damage to
the reputation of the conservative party
for competence and good government the
point about robert jenwick going he was
one of the first alongside rishi sunak
and oliver dowden to endorse boris
johnson he was in the cabinet for many
many months did get into a little bit of
uh difficulty uh over allegations to do
with property developers and the like uh
but nevertheless boris johnson stuck by
him for a long time he is the third of
the three uh
younger mps earlier to back boris
johnson who has now formally broken ties
with the incumbent in number 10 making
life just symbolically yet more
difficult as i was saying earlier there
are two great areas of pressure on the
prime minister one is from the
government itself as people uh resign
from ministerial posts i'm told that
there are more to come and the other is
just from the wider conservative mp uh
group they are waiting for five o'clock
today to hear whether graham brady has
already changed the rules perhaps a week
earlier than possible to make it
possible to have another vote of no
confidence in boris johnson because of
the expectation that events the last
five or so days have dramatically
changed the mood inside the conservative
party and boris johnson would then lose
such a vote potentially uh graham brady
chair of the 1922 executive giving boris
johnson the opportunity to resign rather
than fight and lose
he's always indicated boris johnson that
he would fight but we'd have to see what
happens in that eventuality but the next
few hours with boris johnson before the
days on committee and then that meeting
of all tory mps absolutely critical in
finding out what's going on with the
prime minister
sam coats thanks very much well what
four hours it has been here on sky news
we've seen the prime minister lee for
prime minister's questions a bruising
session of questions including three of
his own mps asking him to resign during
prime minister's questions we then had
sadhu javed making his very very
powerful personal statement on why he
resigned yesterday because he didn't
have faith in the integrity of the
government and then coming up at three
o'clock this afternoon the prime
minister's can be questioned live by mps
at a liaison committee meeting they will
talk to them about the cost of living
but also about integrity in government
stay tuned to sky
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
this is the sarah j michael live from
westminster today as boris johnson
fights to save his career
sinking ships fleeing the rat the labour
leader accuses the pm of losing all
integrity amid fresh calls for him to
resign
in the middle of a crisis doesn't the
country deserve better than a zed list
cast of nodding dogs
21 ministers and aids have now resigned
from the government saying they will no
longer pirouette around fractured values
spreading the tight rope between loyalty
and integrity
has become impossible in recent months
and mr speaker i will never risk losing
my integrity
well there's another big test for the
prime minister this afternoon he will be
grilled by senior mps we'll bring that
to you live at three o'clock
and the group of mps that could seal
boris johnson's fate the touring back
bench 1922 committee meets tonight and
could change its rules to allow a fresh
confidence vote in the prime minister
[Music]
well good afternoon it's been a busy and
fast-moving day so far here in
westminster let's bring you the story so
far boris johnson vowing to stay on as
prime minister this afternoon despite
the growing revolt against his
leadership on a bruising afternoon for
boris johnson he told the commons that
voters had given him a colossal mandate
and he will keep going despite what he
described as difficult circumstances
well what began with the resignations of
the chancellor and the health secretary
last night has now grown into 21
ministers and aides leaving their posts
and at three o'clock this afternoon the
pm will face a grilling from senior mps
on the liaison committee any sure to
face questions over the chris pincher
scandal again which has been dominating
his exchanges with the labour leader
sakir stama at pmq's today
awful behaviour unacceptable in any walk
of life it's there for all to see but he
ignores it
it was the same when his ally was on the
take from the lobbyists
it was the same when his home secretary
was bullying staff
it was the same when taxpayers money was
being abused and it was the same when he
and his mates parted their way through
lockdown anyone quitting now
after defending all that hasn't got a
shred of integrity
mr speaker isn't this the first recorded
case of the sinking ships fleeing the
rats
he talks he talks about
he he should hear what he's not saying
about him uh mr speaker he he talks
about he talks about integrity and he
wanted he wanted to install uh the
member for islington north into number
10 right and mr speaker that's what
that's what he wanted to do imagine
imagine what our country and what the
world would be like now
he talks about integrity he voted he
voted 48 times to overturn the will of
the british people and take us back into
the european union and by the way
listening to his muddled speech the
other day that is exactly what he would
do again